maurice gutman 12 ans fracture de la
hanche droite
une chute dans les escaliers je suis le
docteur d'avril et on peut dire que tu
as de la chance mon garçon de la chose à
l'uaw famille tu vas leur écrire c'est
déjà fait
j'ai eu cette réponse
je te connais toi est nouveau
ah la la la la la
la la la la la mon petit frère adoré ce
livre aussi je veux aller là bas et je
crois que rien
tous paesi danse mazel n'arrête le
yiddish ont d'abord quoi je veux parler
un logiciel tous les enfants buster
pantin il veut des juifs je baisse mon
pantalon que devant les filles la
chanson moi ils font pousser ces deux-là
enfants non pop le noir
chercheur ça fait très longtemps que je
n'ai pas eu de nouvelles j'espère que tu
vas bien
si les allemands que toute la france ce
qui va aussi arrêter les juifs dans la
zone libre mais les grands maintenant on
veut savoir
dans quelques semaines tu pourra
remarcher c'est ça le plus important -
le reste est du passé
ra